Ireland's long-standing constitutional
ban on abortion could soon be over
official counting of the historic
referendum is underway this morning
though it already appears one of the
world's most restrictive abortion bans
will come to an end
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Dublin this
morning with the latest Jonathan good
morning good morning voter turnout in
some areas was as high as 70 percent the
historic vote to legalize abortion shows
an overwhelming desire for a change in a
nation went so closely entwined with
Catholic tradition for months both sides
of this divisive referendum campaigned
in the streets but at the polls the vote
was more unified an Irish Times exit
poll predicts nearly two-thirds of
voters selected yes to repealing
Ireland's eighth amendment the 1983 law
bans all abortions except when a
mother's life is at risk in Europe only
Malta and Poland have similar bans
among those casting their ballots
thousands of returning expats like
sourcer Lowry who flew in from New York
Ireland has leaned more liberal in the
last few decades as the rate of
Catholicism has declined divorce was
legalized in 1995 and gay marriage in
2015 ahead of yesterday's vote the
Catholic Church in Ireland encouraged
its followers to keep the right to life
in the Constitution Ireland definitely
is a beacon for the rest of the world
it's one of the last places that has
really protected women and their
children
from abortion American Emily Faulkner
flew in not to vote but to join the anti
abortion rights campaign roe v wade
legalized abortion in 1973 you would
like to reverse that are you worried
that legalizing abortion here in Ireland
will hurt your effort I will never stop
our fight it will just make us fight
harder against abortion there has been
concern over foreign influence on
Ireland's vote after revelations of
meddling in the u.s. election in an
unprecedented move earlier this month
Facebook and Google banned all
from campaign groups outside Ireland
official results will be released later
this afternoon Parliament will now move
to allow women to have an abortion
within the first twelve weeks of
pregnancy Anthony
Jonathan Vigliotti in Dublin this
morning thanks Jonathan